but we're going to begin with breaking
news out of vivaldi texas the city's
police chief for schools pete arredondo
has been fired for his actions or
inactions during the rob elementary
school massacre back in may he is the
first official to lose his job over a
police response that another agency
called quote an abject failure close
quote 21 people were killed in that
attack 19 of them children the decision
to fire arredondo came during an
emotional school board meeting that
included comments from parents of some
of those children janet shanleyan was
there and she joins us now from vivaldi
janet as i understand it this was a
unanimous decision by the school board
good morning
good morning to you tony parents have
been demanding this move for months they
wanted accountability they wanted
aridando gone but this morning for many
people it seems it's a victory that
appears hollow
the uvalde school board meeting opened
with anger and frustration i have
messages for peter and all the law
enforcement that were there that date
turn in your badge and step down you
don't deserve to wear one
as the board left to deliberate behind
closed doors
victims family members shared their
grief we just want to fight for our
children
and we want them to be remembered
we just want to stop being disappointed
arredondo didn't show his attorneys
instead releasing a 17-page statement it
said no blame should be placed on chief
arredondo for law enforcement's response
to the shooting and it described calls
for his firing as a public lynching
asking the school district to reinstate
him with all back pay and benefits
sir if you can hear me please put your
firearm down sir on the day of the
shooting arredondo attempted to
negotiate with the gunman spending time
searching for a master key to the
classrooms though the door was likely
unlocked
a july report from the texas house
committee said he wasted precious time
and failed to perform in his assigned
role as incident commander
but arredondo has said he didn't believe
he was commander
the report also saddled school
administrators and the entirety of law
enforcement with responsibility for the
tragedy
ultimately 376 officers some armed with
rifles and ballistic shields waited 77
minutes before entering the classroom
where the gunman shot children and
teachers
motion passes unanimously the board
fired eredando by unanimous vote
wednesday after more than an hour in
closed session
for some delayed justice was tainted by
exhaustion and outrage he should be
fired automatic no matter what no pay no
new jobs no nothing just done for pay
when we can't even have our
grandchildren back how dare he
but the feeling is arrogant firing is
not enough it's just the start a 27
billion dollar lawsuit is expected to be
filed on behalf of survivors and
families it will name the uvalde school
district but could also include the law
enforcement agencies that responded as
well as the guns manufacturer
nate
still so much healing to do in that
community janet thank you